Heat current machine learning systems  are mind-blowing and what they can do  but they don't do it like biological  organisms at all it's it's very  different cells do not form change in  which they wait uh sums of real numbers  that there is something going on that is  roughly similar to it but there's a  self-organizing system that designs  itself from the inside out not by a  measure learning principle that applies  to the outside and updates weights after  reading and comparing them and Computing  gradients to the system so this  perspective of local self-organization  by reinforcement agents that try to  trade rewards with each other that is a  perspective that I find totally  fascinating